tiny robots have the potential to do
things like deliver targeted drugs
inside the body but controlling their
position and movements remotely has been
a challenge now a team of researchers
has come up with a new way to use
magnets to fold tiny robots into
different shapes allowing these
remote-controlled micro machines to do
things like grasp objects and crawl
around magnets have been used to control
BOTS before but these other magnetic
minions were stiff because of the
materials used to build them to create a
millimeter scale robot capable of feats
of flexibility the researchers embedded
magnetic particles of the element
neodymium in pliable material the
researchers then used a pair of powerful
magnets to flip the polarity of the
neodymium particles in different
sections of the robot an UV light to
lock them into place by creating
segments of the mini robots that were
attracted or repelled in different
directions the researchers could create
complex 3d movements like grasping
crawling and swimming researchers
designed a few different robots each
with different abilities this robot is
built for gripping objects when the
magnetic field is activated robots arms
fold up like a hand closing around an
apple you can even curl up into a ball
and roll around taking wireless commands
from a scientist using a video game
controller this robot is built like an
accordion and moves around like an
inchworm this robot has a number of
paddles which allows it to crawl across
surfaces like an insect
the most obvious applications for these
tiny magnetic robots are medical but
they could also be used to staff
miniaturized factories building even
smaller goods researchers are hoping to
replace neodymium in future versions of
these robots like lead or mercury
neodymium is a toxic heavy metal that
would need to be removed from inside the
body
if the bots were being used to assist a
surgery or deliver drugs researchers
believe less toxic metals can still work
but may require stronger magnets to be
manipulated the speedy low-cost
manufacturing process researchers
develop
these robots could position them for
widespread success in the medical world
[Music]